[inaudible]
many of you probably think all the
countries in the Arabian peninsula are
insanely wealthy,
right?
I mean this is the region of the wells
where Qatar do volume.
The rest of the oral Monica is our after
all nonetheless arise in this region of
the planet is a country that is
extremely poor.
The place where the GDP per capita lower
than that of Tanzania or Senegal,
the name of this country is Yemen and
they just come with and going through a
civil war that is lost dude for two
years and look this,
this,
it's no small war.
In fact,
the war in Yemen is the Arabian
equivalents to the war in Vietnam and we
find two of the biggest powers in the
Muslim world supporting different sides
of the conflicts.
On the one hand we have the Yemeni
government supported by Saudi Arabia and
all their allies including the United
States and the only other side of there
are the revolutionaries backed by Iran
and between these two sides there is the
many branch of dash or the so called and
saw Al Sharia movement.
Now,
if you've been subscribed to visual
politic for a while,
you already know that Saudi Arabia has
the third best equipped army in the
entire wells boss.
They have the sport of American drones
exams,
the armies of neighboring countries.
They have more than 180 state of the art
combat jets and 300,000 soldiers armed
with the best weapons on the other side.
They have less than half that number of
soldiers and the weapons.
They're armed with our far for modern.
Yeah,
no,
this seems like a pretty unequal fight,
right?
Well,
in that case in mind,
surprise you to learn that Saudi Arabia
is losing this war.
Saudi Arabia says prepared for ceasefire
in Yemen if who feeds agree and so now
you might wonder how exactly is this
possible?
How is it possible to explain why one of
the most advanced armies in the wells
can speak to a bunch of gorillas?
Well,
today we have a geo politic.
we're going to answer that question,
but before we get into any of that,
let's have a look at the history.
The first thing we need to understand is
that this is not the first time Yemen
has had a civil war.
In fact,
this is the third one in just 25 years.
Yemen is a country divided by both
ideology as well as religion.
Indeed,
before the 1990s at Yemen were split
into two different countries.
We had south Yemen with a communist
governments and then there was north
Yemen.
You had a pro Saudi government and going
you want to see on the screen now,
Ali Abdullah Saleh,
who was the president of the north,
started ruling over the entire country
from its capital,
the city of Sonata.
As you can imagine,
slack is one of those politicians who
consider as democracy and human rights
to be wow.
Pretty optional.
Four years into his new country's
history and the former southern
communist leaders started an uprising
against the less governments.
This war only lasted a few months and
the new government is one with the
assistance of the Saudis.
A decade later in 2004 Yemen had further
antigovernment turmoil.
This time the opposition was a rebel
group of Shia Muslims.
I remember their name because they are
important for the war that's going on
today.
If he,
I called the Houthi rebels,
but again,
these are like governments beach down
this uprising.
Second
in 2011 with the Arab spring in full
swing,
the citizens rebelled against seller
again.
But this time salon I left power with
his prime minister Manso this new
president and found himself in control
of a terribly weak governments.
Father Ryle Chi.
Edo we're working on destroying the
country.
And during all of this,
while the protesters,
they kept protesting.
Now do you remember those few rentals?
And we talked about just a moment ago.
Well,
they came back,
but this time they were more powerful
and it's had a lot of support.
And this explains why in 2014 they
managed to take over the government.
Okay,
so now you might be wondering,
what did Al had he do?
Well,
he left the capital Lens,
moved to the city of Arden in the south
of the country to start a provisional.
Governments
not remember him that Saudi Arabia is a
Sunni Muslim country bands.
Well,
who is the biggest enemy of Sunni
Muslims?
Oh yeah.
That would be the Shia Muslims.
These are exactly the people who have
conquered the capital of Yemen,
and this explains why the Saudis aren't
so keen on supporting our hardy and his
provisional governments in arden.
Then finally,
we also have Dash Aka Islamic state in
the next as well,
who all well in enemy of both sides.
All right,
so now we have the Houthi rebels and
their supporters,
the who things are Shia Muslims and
therefore they are friends with Iran.
On the other hands,
Al Hadi is an artisan antia supported by
the Saudis and the Saudis will do
whatever it takes to ensure that Iranian
influence in Yemen is minimized.
You probably remember from one of our
previous videos that Saudi Arabia and
Iran on die on enemies.
Anne's last in 2015 and another year,
many civil war started.
Okay?
Natural fortress.
When we think about Saudi Arabia,
we think of a big desert with clean sand
dunes,
Yemen,
it's rather different.
It is a country full of mountains,
almost as high as the rockies in the
United States.
Some peaks are higher than 3,600 meters.
What if
this makes it really hard to transport a
big army no matter how well equipped us.
For instance,
the Saudis,
they utilize a tank model called the m
one abrams.
This is sort of like the BMW of tax.
Now imagine a convoy of these machines
crossing a path where they have to
travel in singles,
you would just need a few guerrilla
warriors with an RPG seven rocket
launcher to destroy an entire battalion.
The RPG seven is a rocket launcher that
you can see on video games such as call
of duty and it has a market price of
around 3000 US dollars.
The m one Abrams tank on the other hand,
cost around $6 million.
Wow.
Well,
not any that,
as we said at the start of this video,
the Saudi coalition has over 180 combat
jets and also American drones,
but there is a further problem here in
the landscape full of mountains and
caves.
It really is easy to hide from these
drones.
And also even the state of the art of
radars can see in detail what's inside
of the caves
as of course the toothy warriors.
They know the battlefield like the back
of their hands,
and they know where all the good hiding
places are.
In many cases,
they can travel from one village to
another without being exposed to any of
the drone radars.
They can also hide their weapons inside
these caves bus that is still not all
evenly.
These gorillas that have no hummers or
rather modern vehicles,
they have something better.
They have animals.
Oh yes,
you heard that right?
In those high mounds in areas,
the least effective way to transport
something is by using donkeys or
cameron.
So in other words,
the new way of tracking the movements of
these guerrilla warriors is by having
people behind the lines.
Now we're not exactly talking double o
seven like spies heritage rather than
local citizens who are willing to help
or soldiers who are close to enemy
lines.
All right,
so even with these problems,
you might still be wondering how the
Saudis and getting basin the scale
seemed to still be tips pretty far in
Saudi Arabia's favor.
[inaudible]
eight demotivated army.
Now,
many of you might think that the
political system of the country has
nothing to do with the way they organize
their army and conducted.
Whoa.
Well actually in a country like Saudi
Arabia,
they all really connectors in an
absolute monica like they have in Saudi
Arabia.
The royal house cannot trust that army.
Then laying the obsession is keeping
control over the entire military from
the top all the way to the bottom.
This is why the decision making power is
slower than in any other
[inaudible].
Let's
have a look at a hypothetical example
here because it'll illustrate of assets.
Let's imagine a soldier discovers a
machine gun nest that is a three beats
is out in western army such as the
American or British one.
That soldier can easily ask for
reinforcement by radio.
Usually he or she would go alongside
with another soldier from the air force.
You can give the exact coordinates to a
pilot nearby and in a matter of minutes,
a combat jet is bombing the machine gun
nest.
Now let's consider the Saudi Ami
Festival.
That soldier would have to tell the
sergeants and that sergeant,
we'd have to speak to someone higher up
and at the time that decision has really
reached somebody who can actually make
the decision.
It's been longer than an hour.
The 60 minutes here are the difference
between neutralizing and enemy position
and using a soldier.
Yeah.
Awesome.
The same goes for military training.
Most Saudi officials come from the royal
houses and they didn't go through any
sort of academic and military training.
Okay?
They got that position due to pure
nepotism,
and this means,
well,
a distinct lack of knowledge and skills.
The same goes for normal soldiers as
well.
As you probably know in most of these
oil monarchies,
most of the needs of citizens work as
civil servants with sky high salaries.
They really don't know anything about
discipline or hard work.
Okay,
so let's look at an example.
In the video here,
you can see that they don't even know
how to protect the tank with infantry
and don't forget that inside that tank
it's very difficult to see the outside.
This is why a basic principle of war is
that you always want to have soldiers
walking around the tank so that they can
see if something is firing upon it.
This really is wall one o one.
Nevertheless,
the Saudis,
Ms. Dot.
Clawson.
This explains why it is so easy to
destroy their tanks with Sinatra.
Shiva weaponry.
How are we looking at this on the video?
Yeah,
you can see how someone gets close
enough to a tank to put a bomb on it.
Oh,
hand behind.
Surprisingly that he's he rebels have a
much more western management system.
Small groups can react quickly.
Yams,
they do need to go all the way up
through the hierarchy.
Plus then motivation is way higher
because they don't have the option of
just retiring.
Arguably,
they are defending their home from a
foreign army.
In summary,
the war on Yemen is a really excellent
example of how strategy is more
important than weaponry and is that an
authoritarian system makes for a less
efficient.
Oh,
nice.
Sadly,
the fact that the Saudis on losing this
wall doesn't mean they're not killing
people.
In fact,
the opposite,
it's true hole in
Yemen conflict passes 10,000
unfortunately,
what could have been solved in a
peaceful,
democratic way?
It has become a war of attrition that
will leave a footprint on this country
for generations to come and now the
question is,
Dean,
you think the Saudis can turn the table
on this conflict or are we going to see
this conflict last for a long time to
come?
Please do let us know your thoughts in
the comments below.
We'd also like to thank Jaguar Rodriguez
for suggesting the topic for this video.
Django is a military expert from
faint.
Also,
please don't forget to check out the
reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that on auto mine.
I'd also don't forget to subscribe to
our channel.
We publish brand new videos every Monday
and Thursday.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next one.
And if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my love
to voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsideredmedia.com
slash podcast see you there.